what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring the notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and as
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
today I'm reacting to whatever podcast
Lila Rose confronts Justin Waller on
sexual morals um all right let's go
Justin do you ever see yourself getting
married
no not on paper no absolutely not I
believe in love and marriage and in
regards to taking care of a woman fully
and your responsibilities as a father
and a provider fighter and protector 100
in fact I think that's probably what's
broken about the world but in regards to
letting the state get into all my
businesses that took me over a decade to
build absolutely not know how do you
think you're gonna get to the place of
that marriage you want with that family
and
Lifelong Love they just I didn't say I
didn't have family or children I just
said I am in your business oh I see okay
so you want to keep it private is what
you're saying that's what I said well no
he's saying he doesn't want the
government involved so you can do the
ceremony do the ring thing but what does
the government need to be involved
do you Justin might have multiple family
oh you never know I might like family
more than you so much I have five do you
think that's a good thing to have
multiple families I think it's good if
there's one dad and there's not a bunch
of step parents involved and the dad can
be the hero and those five families live
a 10x better life than they would have
otherwise yes ma'am I do but you don't
think that it will be ultimately a an
opportunity for jealousy or disharmony
amongst women are always going to be
jealous what's changed women been
jealous all the way through time you
know what's interesting how like she
automatically makes it about her that's
the interesting thing she's like well
I'm not jealous in my marriage but you
know and I'm I'm someone you know I
believe one okay one I think it's really
hypocritical for the Christians to shame
men about monogamy when women are not
monogamous nowadays because again 95
percent of women are not virgins on
their wedding night so it's like they'll
say well why don't you practice monogamy
but monogamy used to be one partner for
a lifetime not one partner at a time
so when you think about it most
Christians are not practicing monogamy
and I also think it's silly to not
um to say the situation that he's
describing is is like subpart can't work
when it has worked for hundreds of
thousands of years it's not my cup of
tea do you know it's not for me but it's
like I I don't know the like Muslim
Muslims have done that for so long that
there has to be a way to do it that is
effective not jealous in my marriage I
don't care about your marriage I'm
talking about mine well my life is going
to be so I don't answer to you so that's
my answer I'm gonna run my my situation
exactly how I want to and generally when
I do that that's when I have the most
happiness let's say and it's interesting
too because I bet you she comes in and
like shames him for this right and it's
interesting because whenever men are
traditionally masculine right because
he's saying I'm gonna live my life on my
terms then women always want to come in
and like shame them for that that's
that's my guess of how this is gonna if
so so
and you would want that for your
daughters
yeah you see that it's like shaming
language you know
look it they've done it to act like
to act like women are going to be like
traumatized forever from this stuff it's
just like one a lot of women pick
cheaters
and two two you know they've done it in
the East for Generations so there has to
be a way to do it effectively
yeah not my cup of tea please do not
misconstrue this as me saying to do it
but I live my life unapologetically on
my terms so see that's masculinity my
terms right orders that are overly
spoiled and and educated in every way
and have friends all over the world and
World traveled in the best schools in
the world if they have a problem with me
at the end of the day then they can kick
rocks too but you notice how when she
tried to shame him how he was unaffected
yeah so that's what I mean when so
obviously I know there are some people
that if you try to shame them they might
feel ashamed but like I said like if you
are a man who knows your stuff you know
yourself you know who you are it's very
hard for people to shame you an assumpt
for my daughters I'll love them fully
but if they grow up and turn into a
person that doesn't want to get in line
with me or at least look here's my goal
as a parent teach my children how the
world Works give them the skills so they
can live on their own terms and give
them choice if they choose not to make
me part of their life after I've given
them those things I've still succeeded
as a father
a role model for your kids is that part
wow
so now she's like insinuating that he's
not a role model
wow another father should show up in
every way for his children I think I'll
be better than most fathers regardless
of how many children I have I might have
a hundred but you think part of being a
role model it's okay for your kids not
to know even their your relationship
status with their own mom they will know
the relationships with me and their
mother but you have other relationships
with other women too what does that have
to do with anything I'm just wondering
if you think I haven't even said that
I'm just saying like if I want to I will
but you don't think that's a problem for
your daughter to know that about their
dad that's that he well but my my
question is whenever this comes up like
what about the kids in that situation my
question is why do the kids know
the kids would only know if the mother
cannot control her emotions and tells
them and and Jay Waller has been very
open about his views on things so any
woman that picks that knows what she's
getting into
and yet they will still shame him for
that
multiple Mysteries that's up to my
daughter man
you know but do you want your daughter
to have a guy like that long term if he
takes care of her in every way and she
has a much better life because of it
yeah I'm cool with that wait do you want
to have 100 kids is that like Loki and
that's the other problem they don't talk
about is women are not you know even I
don't know how many kids she has but I
guarantee it's less than four you know I
could be wrong they'll be like no it's
five but but you know it's probably if
we're going off of stats it's probably
two
and the average woman used to give a man
five kids so if a guy wants 10 children
how does he get that when women today
won't give it to him so again A lot of
times men adapt to the market and then
we whine about how they adapt I might
have a bunch of kids yeah I believe in
having kids man so there's there's too
many dumb ass people having kids might
as well have a smart person have some
dude is Justin Loki about to repopulate
the world kids are awesome
single-handedly reverse the declining
they got they got all these single women
out here talking [__] about [__] man
well cool I'll have babies with you
what's up now part of it is being a
smart ass right now right to be honest
but look if if a god decides to have a
bunch of children I mean you see it
happen all the time God gets married
he's a shitty father shitty husband ends
up getting a divorce and then goes have
and has babies with the next chick doing
the same thing I'm doing this up I'm not
a lion coward about it I hear you I I
said yeah
men do it all
lives at different times in their lives
wow that's a crazy thing
and I'm not I'm not even Pro like
polygamy like I wouldn't I wouldn't want
to do that but I'm just thinking like
there's no way the whole Eastern side of
the world has done it for Generations
and there's not a way to do it without
the kids being traumatized because we
have more mental disorders now than we
did a hundred years ago look at the
developments in the east
yeah yeah
that's what it is but I think the big
question is I mean it seems like you're
really focused on self-improvement which
is awesome and so I guess my question
would be is it ID like what are we
striving towards individually right and
what do we think is best for society and
I think kids want to know their parents
love each other and are committed till
death do they part to each other yep
didn't say any of that wasn't true but
you're the one saying that's not true
okay but do you think it would be a
little bit
um confusing for one of your kids if
they found out let's say theoretically
because if they trust me enough to come
to me I'll just tell them the truth what
are we talking about I'm not hiding from
anything I just told you I understand
that it seems like you're challenging
because you have a problem with it I
simply don't care
so your your kids you're saying you
don't care if they find out you have
multiple Mistresses if I had multiple
women and then my kids came to me
then I would just talk to them like a
like an adult if they're adult enough to
ask I'm adult enough to tell them
well well okay but this goes back
why does a sick a six-year-old know
how would a six-year-old find this out
as your mother you're supposed to
protect your kids from this information
so one any girl that signs up to be with
him knows what she's signing up for and
they find out because the mothers go
talking to the kids yeah I know I know
ask I'm there for
you know that's it
find somebody else I don't feel bad I'ma
live in truth here's the difference
between me and most men most men are
doing this [__] behind people's back
right like a [__] coward and they're
not even giving the family the life that
they deserve so if I choose to do that
in the future which I have not said I'm
gonna do
then so be it but if I don't I don't I
hear you I I guess that you're saying
you don't want to share your
relationship status but then you just
said you people are hiding it and being
a coward so I guess I think there's a
difference between not wanting to share
one's relationship status publicly on a
platform like this versus when I have a
big internet following and like
offices that you can Google and all
kinds of things like that I don't want
to I don't want that smoke for people in
my life I see yeah can I ask you one
more question fire away okay if you have
a place in only one place in your heart
for one woman or you want to have one
woman in your heart I think you said why
don't you just commit to one and choose
to be faithful to her
I'm just not worried that way I want to
listen to this again in one place okay
um if you have a place in only one place
in your heart for one woman or you want
to have one woman in your heart I think
you said why don't you just commit to
one and choose to be faithful to her
because she's conflating like men
committing
men commit in a different way than women
women commit sexually men don't men like
men can sleep with another chick and
feel nothing now God it so irritates me
because I've almost been labeled as this
woman that like pushes for men cheating
when I don't say that but I just think
we need to get off of our high horse
when most women do not come into
marriage as virgins so in a way if you
didn't do that you cheated on your
future husband because it's expected for
the woman to have Purity it's not
expected for the man and it's it's just
almost an in even exchange of value so
it's like if a single mother goes into a
marriage and gets cheated on
couldn't you argue it's still a fair
exchange because she's coming into a
marriage with another man's kid
I think the reason why feminism and
modern ideologies try to fight against
all this like Purity talk and others
because
back in the day traditional men used to
bring masculinity protection provision
and women need to bring Purity but
because women are not pure anymore so
they just want to scrap everything and
say well women don't need to bring
anything to the table
yeah yeah but it's interesting because
it's like the the marriage thing kind of
it I'm not I'm pro-marriage but in terms
of exchange of value it makes sense when
the man and the woman get married young
because the woman gives her you so she
gets married at 20 years old so say
she's a 20 year old Birch and then it
makes sense because she gets the
protection and provisioning from the man
for a lifetime and he wouldn't step out
right so he's saying you know what my
mating strategy is typically to screw
all these women so I'm gonna I'm gonna
hold back on that and I'm gonna
compromise for you and she says you know
my mating strategy is to go for the best
man I can even the girls I was showing
you that were like virgins on their
wedding day their husbands weren't like
the crazy like high value men they were
fine you know but like they probably
could have you know hypothetically done
like higher in this day and age right so
it's like the woman compromises on her
mating strategy by saying you know what
I could search the world I could search
the whole state for the best guy in the
state but instead I'm gonna I think
you're a good bet I'm gonna I'm gonna
marry you and let's have a family so
they're both compromising but it's like
when the woman now doesn't have purity
um she doesn't have youth you know the
average bride is 31 years old it now
becomes an uneven exchange of value so
you know one way that hypothetically you
could make it more even is the man gets
to fulfill his mating strategy and sleep
with multiple people or have multiple
women
um
not not to say we should do that but you
know it's more of like a thought
experiment you know
um but it's interesting because the harp
on the men for this but I never hear the
Christians or like the chadcons harp on
the women and say you are not worth
being a wife if you are not a virgin you
are supposed to be a vert like I have
never heard this I've only heard about
the Redemption I have never and the
worst part is do you know what they try
to compare it to they try to compare
women not being virgins to men watching
porn it is not the same yeah I know I
know because women do not value men for
their purity I know I know it comes with
problems but is it acting like this is
the same and has the same effects on a
marriage it's just that's just silly
I'm just now wired that way I spent my
whole 20s trying to fix it in fact the
man can't even like like a man is very
hard for you to find a pure man
because even if you were to remove sex
out of it the world doesn't allow for
men to be pure
like the world we live in the physical
world we live in if you're pure you're
gone you're going to right because it's
a good thing yeah well even because also
if you yeah because women want a man
that's more experienced and like good
and bad literally have to be like apart
from the sex even like physically you
have to for you to be desirable woman
you literally have to almost be a
monster well and and too
it's like even if you want to be pure
how could you and women are walking
around half naked all the time even if
you wanted to it's like they shove it in
their face you work out you do business
you can possess your own your own power
and you've directed that's not how I am
that's not how I am you think that might
be a limited mindset
I think it's none of your business but I
don't want you to think I'm triggered by
you I'm not okay I saw somebody say that
and I think that's interesting I think
you're annoying but I'm not sure you
know what I'm saying no you are you're
annoying in like this goody two shoes
type way and that's fine uh I'm gonna
live my life on my terms but see that's
so interesting do you see it guys though
this is what I talk about with like the
Christians yeah I gotta say it it's like
whenever he says I'm gonna live my life
on my terms I'm gonna do what I want
Christians and like tradcons will always
say like the men need to be better for
the women so it's like when when they
say you know what you need to be the
best version of yourself so you have all
the leverage and she has to live life on
your terms no they'll say that way you
can be a better husband for a family
that way you can have a family when it's
like that's the female's mating strategy
so it's that it's kind of it's in
reality do women need to be better so
they can have a family because it's the
man that is going to protect
you get like you can't say the man needs
to be better because already
he's as a man the only thing that
changes when you get married is that you
just have in fact in reality today
the things that change when you get
married is that you become less
masculine so it's not it's not even
initially it's not it's not even a plus
these days to say yeah I'm getting
married among men because we all we all
kind of know where that part typically
leads but I mean
just a thought
unapologetically like truly so uh you
can ask me this 85 different ways at the
end of the day I'm gonna walk out of
here the same man I have a question do
you think marriage should be public
what do you mean do you think that when
you commit your life to someone and
you're going to build a family with them
do you think that should be done in
community so public I I think that's up
to the people that do it I don't think
there's a right way to do it at all so
it's up to you so you think like for
children they shouldn't they don't have
the right to know whether or not their
parents are married and be able to feel
that when they're going to society yeah
I think that if you're if your kids ask
you should tell them the truth 100
there's no lie or no nothing I would
ever keep from a child of mine meaning
the truth about no we're not married no
I think you do need to shelter kids from
certain things I do I don't know why
kids need to like I don't think you need
to know everything as a kid I think
there's adult talk and there's kid talk
other people I'm sleeping with
whatever they ask me I would answer
no no no no no
you know I mean you could live your life
how you
if I was in that situation I would want
lies yes I would sorry I would I
wouldn't even lie to them they're just
some things that um like I just thought
the kids yeah you just told them you
would that's like my mom used to tell us
about certain things she would just give
us like a general idea but she would
tell us you would you understand when
you get older and we did understand
I think I somebody that was raised by a
single mom like those things they they
don't matter as much to your child as
you think that they may I mean it did
have an effect on my relationships going
growing up but it's also there's a
girl's on my show she's not only fans it
does have an effect you can learn from
that experience through your parents you
know like you can as long as you have
open communication with your child no
like what because then my question is
okay what outcomes did you have she's
not only fans like dude and I don't have
any children but I have younger siblings
and I'm openly communicative with all my
family members I think what's most
important when it comes to kid is their
love in the house do they see love
between their parents not not are they
living the way of of making people that
go to church happy it's a very downward
deflecting question you're asking me and
I understand why you're doing it however
I'll put love first in front of marriage
every day of the week because people get
married in America every weekend putting
the marriage and the Facebook pictures
before the actual love so I'll take the
love over all the [__] I think
that's probably true there's a lot it's
definitely true there's a lot of
hypocrisy out there for sure so a lot of
hypocrisy and Christianity as well like
Bible thumping people that want to beat
you up with their views and ask silly
questions about things that don't matter
like is your kid going to be upset that
you have other women all I'm worried
about is being a good [__] father and
a provider you know what's interesting
too uh the Marxist stuff is in the
church because they like literally sent
people to infiltrate the church so a lot
of the like feminist talking points
you'll hear the same language in the
church like it's very very similar like
you can hear the shaming language she's
using it's so funny because everyone on
social media like
um I I I recognize it later but I
realized I've seen like a small clip
from this
and I couldn't see the context of the
clip but I I thought
it was so interesting everyone thought
she won and like oh you're like oh yeah
I know but when you watch the full video
I'm like oh he's making way more sense
but
and that's the other thing they're
trying to impose their religious beliefs
on other people
when you know there's certain religions
that are for that like there's certain
religions that say you can have four
wives you know and I think it's a bit I
just think it's so silly to act like the
kids will all be traumatized just
because he has multiple wives like get
out of here and giving them a life full
of love and if I can do that I've been
quite quite successful in fact I'd say
more successful than most Christians so
my understanding my understanding of
Love is that it is totally wanting the
best for the other person and that it's
committed and that it's sacrificial and
that it's exclusive it's faithful and
Fidelity I think is a really important
part of love and if you don't have
Fidelity and love then you don't have
the security and the opportunity do you
know what's interesting I just want to
see something what's her name Lila I was
like I don't see your husband anywhere
on here I was like but it's interesting
because
so I see like one picture of her and her
husband
and like the rest
is her talking
her on you know and I'm not even saying
I really I don't want this to come
across like ashaming her because I
actually I don't think her Instagram's
bad at all but but it's interesting how
we shame like okay if you think sex and
attention sex is to men what attention
is to women in a way we have wives and
mothers with open Instagram accounts and
you know she has an open Instagram
account right and she's got like
pictures of her by herself on there with
like a picture of her smiling so in a
way aren't you sort of accepting
attention from other men when Instagram
is the number one way of like
people dating nowadays not not to say
she's like doing anything about it but
it's just interesting like the hypocrisy
when it's like I think it opened
Instagram account is equally as bad as a
guy cheating like I think it's the same
maybe not the same
but but you kind of see where I'm going
a bit with it it's like a bit it's a bit
hypocritical can I throw a hypothetical
at you yeah please do if and this is a
hypothetical please so please don't get
offended but if your husband were to do
something that was not okay with you
whatsoever to the point where you did
not any longer want to be with him
whether that's cheating or something
else that's just a no for you
would you leave she would stay would you
leave them to just please your your
children and to keep your family
together is that like some you're
willing to risk your own happiness and
well-being or even safety if it was
something that was that extreme are you
talking about abuse I'm I'm using a
hypothetical okay whatever it is that
would be like a straight like I need to
leave this person would you stay with
them just for the convenience and also
the toxicity that it could bring into
your household in inflicting your your
children you know so my position is if
and it's the position of the Catholic
Church as well which is that if you're
in a situation in a marriage that's
abusive right it's causing harm to you
or your children then you definitely
should create separation you should
leave you can actually get a legal
divorce if you need to separate your
assets but the position of the church
and that's based that part's based
belief is that marriage is forever
um until death was part until death was
part so you can marry someone and they
become a screwball you know they totally
mess up they they do bad bad things and
you should separate yourself from them
for your protection or your kids
protection but you then don't go on and
just remarry and try to live another
life now there's something in the case
if you were lied to so there's something
called annulment which some people say
oh that's Catholic divorce it's actually
not annulment is when the mayor it says
if the merits never happened because
it's people were lying typically when
they go into the marriage so like
typically abusers don't just start
abusing after marriage they're abusing
it's not just us yeah or they're lying
so if they're lying to you in a serious
way and you go into a marriage you
weren't free able to freely choose that
marriage and so afterwards you can
request an annulment from the church and
be like hey I don't think I was even
married because I didn't freely choose
this I didn't know this guy was a liar
and you know addicted to pornography and
abuse and all these things and so in
that case you could nullify the marriage
and then be free to be free to actually
get married I want to say something just
to be completely fair to you I think
what you have in your marriage is
absolutely beautiful no problem with it
at all I think that if you two are happy
and like living together in the Lord and
like you see a future that even that
goes past this life to Heaven I think
that's a beautiful beautiful thing no
issue at all well you should be
commended for doing it you know properly
well but not properly in regards your
religion I don't mean to cut you off but
properly in regards to like what you are
setting out to do with him I think
that's a beautiful thing well we're
definitely imperfect people figuring it
out right and that's what part of
marriages is becoming better together
you know in that total commitment to
each other
um but the thing is like I'm passionate
about not just wanting it for myself
right like I'm very grateful to be
married it has rooted my life it has
anchored my life it has changed my life
but I don't want to just keep that to
myself and be like oh this is just my
personal thing over here I want other
people to re to have the opportunity for
that what do you think it takes for
women to get in a position to find a
husband that will commit to them fully
and give their life to them what do you
think that takes well I think the first
step is uh working on yourself and your
own development as a woman becoming the
best that you can be and then having
good standards for the man that you're
going to be with like to be perfectly
wait why wow
she literally said wow
what a woman needs to do to get a good
husband is have good standards for the
man she didn't say anything about
herself
wait I maybe she'll go into it maybe
let's give her let's give her the
benefit of the doubts with you I would
not ever date a guy who I thought would
be unfaithful to me not even date him
never if I found out my person I was
dating is sleeping with other women or
sleeping with anyone honestly because I
don't I didn't have we didn't have sex
before marriage I'd be like no was she a
virgin
I don't know if she's a virgin I'm not
interested but I asked you what you
think a woman needs to do yeah yeah do
you see how it's like the feminist
programming it's like
and what we need to do is have high
standards but it's like if you're a used
Honda Civic and you demand Ferrari
prices you're just going to have no
buyers so I would I would say high
standards is not the problem in the
dating market today and it's it's funny
because the married people will [__] on
me for being single like they'll just be
like oh she's single she doesn't know
what she's talking about but sometimes I
hear the married people talk and I'm
like I don't think you guys know what
you're talking about because the market
is different than 10 years ago it is
absolutely different I think the woman
needs to become the best she can be she
needs to grow psychologically be healthy
if she needs to heal from trauma from
her childhood a lot of us have baggage I
had baggage go get the therapy that you
need but see all of the things she's
listing is what the woman can do to be
better for herself I haven't heard
anything that she could do to be better
for her husband maybe I will I'm going
to give her the benefit of the doubt
really understand it do not do not
believe that that therapy is in the
church in Christianity do I not believe
what do you not believe it's everything
that you need is at church you can't
just find that in the word well the
beauty of so the beauty of Catholicism
is it's very much focused on the whole
person right so it's not like we're just
Spiritual Beings right we're also bodies
with desires with traumas with with
experiences and so the psychological
world and you know psychological health
is an important part of bodily Health
um and it connects to your spiritual
health so therapy is great you know
obviously we totally promote therapy for
those that need it mental health is
really important so just because you're
doing the right thing spiritually
doesn't mean you're necessarily mentally
healthy you may need to get mental
health support too I think this is
actually something a lot of I still
haven't heard anything that we
and and
if she wanted to argue from the
Christianity standpoint she's she's
conflating a lot of things and she's
just going off point the reality is
Justin was right he said shouldn't you
get all that from the church if you're a
true Christian or your therapy
would come from the church because the
reality is a lot of mental illness and
all these things actually come from sin
yeah if you're looking at it from the
Christian point of view the reason why
you would run into problems is when you
stray away from God and when you stray
away from his grace that's when you
start running into all these mental
issues you start
abusing alcohol doing all this crap yeah
but if you're in the spirit if you're
connected to God
you would like you how can you be
mentally ill how
to show you because when you see the
people that are the most mentally ill
you see what the choices they make in
their lives yeah people who are really
spiritual fall into they think oh if I'm
just pray enough I can make my
depression go away right and yes
sometimes God does just heal depression
like that but a lot of the time God uses
natural means like a good therapist you
know a good psychiatrist to help
somebody through oh no no you're sending
them to the crazy ladies and
I'm not saying there aren't good
therapists
but I'm saying that most are pretty
shitty most yes The Human Condition is
that things aren't always amazing right
we have bad days we get sick terrible
accidents can happen and so that's where
the power of love comes in a love that
doesn't leave a love that doesn't isn't
based on feelings or desire but a love
that's based on choice and I think deep
down we're all wired for that even men
even men that like like you were saying
Justin I want to be with multiple women
and everything I think deep down we want
a love that stays a love that lasts and
it is possible for everyone every single
person at this table I guarantee you a
thousand percent it is possible for you
not for asexual yeah but I would argue
that like who are you to tell me that
I'm not going to be happy because I
don't choose your path yes I don't think
I said that that pretty much oh you kind
of did
you're like oh what about the kids I
mean
so who are you to say that I will say
you think I'm going to be less happy
than you I think that if you live your
life and you said you're not sharing
whether or not you're doing this so
we're all talking in hypothetical so I
don't know exactly how you're living
right you didn't share that but if
hypothetically you live your life where
you are starting multiple families with
multiple women what if I have one family
and 50 girlfriends I think in the end it
will bring great unhappiness to your
family to your children to the mother of
your children that actually sounds like
every man's dream I'm not gonna lie like
I know like it would come with a lot of
problems I'm not even promoting this but
if I think of like the typical guy would
he want a girlfriend and to be able to
screw
girls on the side if the wife could
control her emotions about it that
sounds like a man's dream am I Am I
Wrong Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I don't know
what do you think
sounds like a bit of a dream
like reality you know
there would be problems like it's like
with it but
but would a guy be so upset and like
depressed he's like sitting oh my life
is so horrible because I have a wife and
a bunch of girls like I'm just thinking
how this sounds that's like telling a
woman if you married rich to a hot
successful billionaire you're gonna be
depressed I think women can find ways to
be depressed
[Laughter]
that it's the equivalent it's the
equivalent okay men have always led the
world listen let's not act like that's
not the case we invent build and
maintain Society the fact that despite
how beautiful you are you're stunning
the fact that you can make more money
than the [__] that paved the
road for me to get here is a joke yep
it's a [__] joke and it's broken now
that's not disrespect to you but one
thing I will say about Dubai if you
don't bring Dubai back up is that you
can't do that [__] in the buy yeah okay
no you no you can't you can't even get
on a porn site to buy if you wanted to
and I one thing I think in Dubai you
just can't do it
they take it away and for that I will
say when I'm in Dubai not only is it
safer but you see more families in Dubai
you see more you see kids you see things
like this it's a beautiful thing and you
know I'm all about people having their
free rights and everything but I do
think Dubai gets that right because if
America doesn't do something to save the
men so men can be good enough to get
good beautiful women like you ladies
then we are always going to have this
problem regardless of religion this is
why we should ban porn in America I'm
about it I could get behind that I could
ban I'd ban birth control and porn
yes and divorce in Pearl's world
I'm about but I'm all about banning porn
because what's happening it's so funny
how the women are more upset about it
than the guys right now no wait look
look
but the point is this what's happening
go ahead one quick thing is um perhaps
the women at this table haven't been
hurt by a man cheating on them or a
boyfriend or something cheating on them
porn or cheating with another person but
I know people that have been hurt and
probably we know people who have been
hurt
yeah exactly so so like what's the
Golden Rule right do unto others how
you'd want them to do okay then delete
your Instagram
this is uh what I what I I'm not pro
cheating and I hate I hate that I've now
become an advocate for cheating what I
hate is the shaming of men for doing
something that women do all of the time
in relationships even religious women
have open Instagrams that men can
message them on
I do not like the hypocrisy that's what
irritates me if you're going to shame
Jay waller for cheating I would like the
same level of shaming to a woman with an
open Instagram that posts bikini
pictures
and even not even bikini pictures
because when you think about it when
you're taking a picture of your face
you're saying look at my face this is my
beauty you're showing your beauty to the
world and
I understand we got we got Brands we're
like you know doing all this stuff and I
understand I understand it but my point
is we don't have the same level of like
shaming for something that is the same
thing in a different way maybe not the
same I was thinking about this maybe
it's not the same level of it but it's
still the same thing in a different way
and that's what irritates me
you right and so I think that's really
you mentioned a crisis of masculinity I
think there's a crisis of femininity too
because you know we set the standard as
women right like that's part of our I
agree with this I think I think I agree
with where she's going well in society
of saying like we're gonna have
boundaries we're going to have standards
for the men and that they need to rise
to the occasion for us but I would argue
there's just as many men wait wait wait
wait she did it again wait wait she did
it again
it's so in the language listen part of
our role in society of saying like we're
going to have boundaries we're going to
have standards for the men and that they
need to rise to the occasion for us they
need this is the whole point they need
to rise to the occasion not for
themselves but for women
you hear it it's like and I'm sure I've
used this language at some point in my
life but it's like it's so programmed
like into the language she didn't even
say we need to have
um boundaries or standards for ourselves
she said for the men why why why would
you have
its own is very backwards thinking in my
opinion it's like it's almost it's like
pointing at the
um spec in someone's eye when you have a
log in yours yeah well and I'm thinking
like wait what about let's have higher
standards so we can be more pure for our
husbands and so it's funny because it's
still like the me me culture where even
when she's like speaking about how to be
better women it's still for me me me me
it's not for him am I crazy or how about
we have better standards for ourselves
so that we can attract
because if you look at him men pursue
women attract right so if you're
attracting you you can only set
standards for people you are going after
you can't you can't it's like you need
to set standards for yourself since
you're attracting and then whenever
whoever comes to you obviously if they
don't meet if they don't match who you
are as a person
then they don't match
boys like you're not even you don't even
match the standards you're setting for
the guy but I would argue there's just
as many male feminists as there are
women yes let's see [__] are
the ones that's messing everything up
young beautiful girl would be much
happier if there's a man that you could
be inside of his frame and not be
talking to weirdos on the internet I
know you make a lot of money and and I
don't blame you for doing it 70 grand a
month that's good money but ideally for
you if there was a man but the problem
also is the standards do you know what I
mean like what would she be willing to
go
live with a masculine man in an
apartment while he saved up so they
could buy a house
no
not when she's made not when she has
made 70k in a month in a year before
I've always felt like
money doesn't really change you it just
shows you who you are
like even
just like alcohol just like substances
they don't make you a different person
it just he removes in inhibitions right
so you have all these walls built up
then when you take alcohol you remove
the walls and then your true self comes
out it's the same with money
yeah yeah well because I was thinking
about how I was about myself and I was
how neither of us like have really been
into like designer or all that stuff and
it's kind of like if you spend your
money when you're broke on that stuff
you'll do the same thing when you're
rich it just keeps going yeah and I was
thinking well I don't know what her
lifestyle is but I understand why men
are so frustrated that they feel like
they have to maintain a lifestyle
because especially because I think about
these things because I don't I don't do
them
um like when it comes to like I mean
some of it but like the nails the fake
hair the botox the the lip filler all
that [__] that the BB has all that stuff
like it's so expensive that I often
wonder in the new clothes the
fashionable like in style clothes I
always think I'm like how do they afford
it they they can't they have to be
living off of credit cards or something
because the average chicks making like
35 40 000 a year
and and this is why once a woman gets
sucked into that life she really can't
be with a regular guy anymore yeah
because a regular guy can't afford to
maintain that lifestyle for her yeah and
she'll present the one that can't
because again she feels like she's
better than the man because she's being
subsidized by Beauty
inside that frame and you who knew he
had everything taken care of completely
you would put it down and and it's not
anybody's fault but weak men that a
young lady like this is having to do
something like that because ah okay
that's simping a little bit
uh just I like Justin and this is this
is simping it's nobody's fault but weak
men that she has to do that that is not
true no it is not around that she can
identify as well men are providers and
we are the caretakers and I because of
how again you guys were saying it weak
men for that reason I was raised where
you don't rely on anybody you get your
bag by yourself and that's for that but
whose fault is that why isn't your mom
with your dad who's whose fault is that
why did she pick your dad if he's not
around reason my household was very
traditional yeah we were still raised
because of how the world was turning
that you wait she was from a traditional
house I think I kind of understand why
women want men to accept this bad
behavior from women so badly I think
it's because women already accept bad
behavior for men
so they they think men should accept
back there for women because a woman
would readily like she would know that
this guy made his money from being a
criminal and she will readily sleep with
him
because what he said I've changed or
whatever
so oh wow yeah that's so true yeah so
they expected we almost like it better
because he's got like a yeah yeah so
they think it should be the same like if
we can accept a guy that's probably
killed a couple of people robbed this
person Rob that person then you should
accept me you don't understand it
because we don't we don't like the
innocent guys we don't like that we like
the bad guy well we like the innocent
girl yeah yeah so it's like we're
putting our the way we look at the world
on men wow
you've been insightful lately King this
red pill stuff is is is getting to you
in the same on the opposite side of the
spectrum as a single girl that does of
guys completely discredit me the second
they find out what I do and I I base
I'm not I'm not saying I'm not in the
point in my life where I'm like oh yeah
I need I need a boyfriend I'm just
saying like it can be just as difficult
on the other opposite side of the
spectrum so don't don't put yourself
down or compare yourself because if you
compare yourself to other people then it
takes the gratification out of your own
your own success your own happiness it's
not worth it you're very smart I can
tell and do you do you want to be a role
model for other people ultimately
what what uh what is our obsession with
that question though
I don't know
person I believe that I can do both and
it not be a degrading like me not I'm
not I mean you can't no you can't buy
buy I'm gonna get women are gonna put in
your body
give me the rapper do you think that we
should have young girls looking up to
like yeah
do you think that the dream of a young
girl
let me ask the question okay yeah but
she's bro she's like making noises we're
done we're done um L do you think that
the dream of a young girl should be to
be an only fan
I think that a young woman should have a
choice to do what she wants with her
body and that it shouldn't be frowned
upon to do whatever means necessary to
be independent and that's my opinion and
you don't have to agree with it and you
don't have to agree with the way that I
make my money and I what
oh my goodness that's right as you see
that he puts as well I'm very sure that
if women had the same strength as men
oh or the world will have been an even
more dangerous place oh yeah women are
more likely to wage war and I totally
understand it there's a reason for
biology there's a reason why we're
designed where we are yeah there is a
reason there's a reason why women are
not giving superhuman strength like men
there is a reason
deserve that right for yourself and I
respect that opinion I do I think it's
powerful that you're allowed to have
that opinion but I don't think that I
need to agree to it or co-sign it but I
think we all just had this conversation
Chase was talking about asking questions
I think we were kind of all mostly
agreeing maybe not every single person
but most of us were agreeing that you
know porn has really hurt Society at
large and we wouldn't want to be in a
relationship with a man who looked at
porn a lot of men on only fans are fans
are married men who are looking at the
porn and their wife is you know they're
being cheated on basically so I mean
that role model that you want to be all
right his job to step up and take the
market away and it's back to what I said
earlier men have always led the world
why are we going to act like it's
women's fault but I I actually do think
it's more
so they all saying
they'll say it's women's fault I'll tell
you why
wild uh it depends do you believe that
sex is a need for men if if you think it
is not then you may have a different
opinion I think it is
um I've heard there's research that
indicates it is so if we think that sex
is a need and the women are not sleeping
with the men that like they're only
sleeping with 20 percent of men 30 even
if you want to say they're sleeping with
50 of that
let's up it to 50 well what are the
bottom 50 percent of Men supposed to do
and yeah um actually like Justin I think
is a cool guy he was here I mean I'd
have nothing against him but this is the
one thing I disagree with him on yeah I
actually think he should actually know
better because the reality is he keeps
saying man should step up there again
but the reality is even if every single
man on Earth today was to step up their
game become a millionaire become this
and that and become desirable nothing is
going to change because the bar will
just be lifted Higher by the women yeah
because there will still always be a top
section of men yeah all the women would
still go for oh that's so true like
saying the men need to step up their
game doesn't make any sense
always want to look for the guy at the
top no matter how much everybody steps
up their game yeah that's like the
husband's story have you heard that
analogy yeah yeah yeah and it's just
like the million story as well if
everyone was a millionaire then a
million being a millionaire would be
like being poor right right if there was
no platform for her to make this kind of
money on she wouldn't be doing it if men
were better she would be with a
different man it is men's jobs to take
this responsibility and stop subscribing
to it not the girl's fault because the
girl has no man to get under and get
behind and believe it oh shut up I'm
sorry I Justin
I just know them you kind of want to be
like a big fan but but
you're telling me that chick with the
tattoos what would you rate her one to
ten
on the the blonde yeah yeah her hmm
I'd say eight my gut's eight what do you
think could have been a nine without
those tattoos
well yeah eight right you're telling me
an eight
couldn't find a guy to do that for her
and her only option was only fans okay
maybe one of the other chicks on the
panel
didn't have the same I don't know maybe
the chicken and the pink I mean I don't
know they all whatever like
in today's world they probably all would
have been able to get like a maybe a guy
that ends ATK up yeah but that's the
thing they don't want a guy that ends
ATK they want a guy against 250k yeah
and to marry no man to be submissive to
and so the only thing that's out there
is for her to make money with this easy
way because he's nah I don't think
that's true okay all right hold on hold
one quick thing one thing I really
appreciate about what you're saying
Justin is that you're saying men need to
take response
I like how she only agrees when it's
like for the women thing it's always
been this way so for us to flip it on
the chicks now I think is dumb agree but
I would just argue that women are strong
we have agency we can make decisions I
agree with some of the language coming
out of the side of the table that we
make decisions we make choices we should
use that power for what end right it's
not like men of all the power women have
no power of choice women have the power
to decide the standards that we hold
ourselves to and that we hold men to and
the kind of women we want to be and the
kind of role models we want to be for
the next Generation right and the truth
is is that if we took porn away from
young men that they would be
incentivized to go become that strong
man I'm all for getting rid of porn I'm
all for them I am about that like I said
even if all men start going to the gym
there's still going to be a hierarchy of
strength yeah we cannot all be equally
as strong as each other
we do I love that and everybody in our
everybody in this space there were a lot
of people in this space would would
naturally easy decision almost 100 out
of 100 say get rid of porn I I'm always
so how could we do that
like how that's a great question all the
women are like no my 70k a month which I
don't even believe they make that much
70k I don't believe it I was looking at
the numbers for like what only fans
chicks make there's only like 3 000
people in the US that make that much
you're telling me I was on a table with
three of them someone's lying I don't
know who someone's lying well that that
gets to like a governmental level yeah I
mean we'd have to legislate legislative
well I think it's it's
legislation that can be done to ban porn
because I think it is that would go back
to making the United the United States
of America have its Christian
backgrounds come on stand up to the
point where people would go vote for it
in that way but I think the other thing
is yeah thing too is it kind of takes a
leap of faith as women because if
culture is demanding from us right I
mean that's what you guys are we're
dealing with cultures we're swimming in
is sexually objectifying women rewarding
women for sexual objectification right I
like how that was my thought when
they're like they're because I never
understand when they're like they're
sexually objectifying women when the
women are like like dude I mean it
almost takes the responsive when they
say women are being objectified it
sounds like someone else is doing it
when we're objectifying ourselves yeah I
know but it kind of shows this argument
in real time because she's saying I like
it you know it could be like because I
just don't like this idea that the women
are just victims like oh I was just so
broken and because that's what they do
in the church they'll just say I was so
broken and lost so I ran through like I
got ran through and then I met my
husband later like long story short they
say I'm insensitive for describing it
this way but that's what happened I went
on this podcast on Tim cast that's the
same as guy said to me when I I said um
that he mentioned this Christian I feel
bad he knew him but they went to my high
school to give us a chance did he talk
and literally I was thinking when they
did this Chastity talk because the woman
said that she got ran through and then
found a husband at the end like she you
know stopped having sex and then found
her husband and I was like this is kind
of a poor message for a woman because it
says you can do whatever you want and
then get a husband at the end and apart
from that I think that's another thing
that's actually stopping women from
finding commitment I think if women
where
if women felt more shame and kept their
mouths shut
more women would get away with doing
some of this stuff because I think men
if they knew that their womb their women
were truly remorseful about what they've
done in the past and they are willing to
to make sure that they don't
um willingly give out that information
themselves I think some men will still
take the deal but these days women are
even proud after being mothers to go and
speak about their only fans that they've
done in the like why would you do that
or like I think guys would accept it to
no one else knew yes yeah if no one else
knew and the woman is is willing to make
sure that she never speaks about it
again but the more than likely she is
going to have one drink and start
talking about and start telling everyone
about how she did only fans and how she
slept with four guys and how she did
this it's like come on yeah
but I I do think there's a rule of
personal responsibility that women were
not doomed to anything we can make any
choice we want and we can start over we
can do walk a different path and we can
be the women that we dream to be that
isn't just she's still maybe she did I
know this is Clips but she still has not
mentioned anything that we can do other
than therapy
and raising our standards I'm like this
is a problem money on the internet one
way we can I am the woman I dream to be
I've arrived and I'm so happy with her
this is I actually think that was so
important sorry I think that was so
important important because it shows
that we are not these victims that the
Trad cons are trying to say it's like in
in your face do they seem like victims
that don't know what they're doing
no
um they might not understand the
consequences that comes later but
okay anyways guys um let me know what
you think in the comment you know am I
off base with this stuff maybe I am
maybe I'm not but I will only know I
will only find out your opinion if you
let me know in the comments so make sure
you leave a comment like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time